they happen to have a coffee bar uh in
the lobby of the four seasons in vegas
and so one afternoon i went and bought
myself a cup of coffee and uh the
barista working that day was a kid named
noah
noah was funny and charming and engaging
and i spent far too long buying a cup of
coffee because i just so enjoyed talking
to noah so as is my
nature i asked noah
do you like your job
and without skipping a beat noah said i
love my job now in my line of work
that's significant
like is rational i like the people i
like the i like the work you know i get
paid well i like my job love is
emotional it's a higher order connection
right like do you love your wife i like
her a lot right clearly
it's clearly a different standard right
so when noah said i love my job my ears
perked up this kid has an emotional
connection to his work
so immediately i followed up and said
tell me specifically what the four
seasons is doing that you would say to
me you love your job
and again without skipping a beat noah
said
throughout the day managers will walk
past me and ask me how i'm doing ask me
if there's anything that i need to do my
job better not just my manager any
manager
and then he said i also work at another
hotel
and there the managers walk past us and
catch us when we do something wrong
there the managers are always trying to
drive performance and make sure we hit
our numbers he said there i'd like to
keep my head below the radar get through
the day and just collect my paycheck
only at the four seasons do i feel i can
be myself
now this is the exact same human being
working at two different companies
and yet our experience of him will be
profoundly different
not because of him
but because of the leadership
environment in which he works
you know i get this question all the
time you know simon how do we get the
most out of our people people are not a
towel that you wring them out to see how
much you can get out of them
you know it's it's a it's it's
it's
that's a good one man
it's a flawed question the question is
how do we create an environment on in
which our people can work at their
natural best and that is the art of
leadership
it's creating environment in which
relationships can thrive in which trust
can thrive and we all know what it feels
like to be on a trusting team
right
it means that we feel
psychologically safe enough
to raise our hand and say um
i made a mistake
or i need help
or i'm having trouble at home and it's
affecting my work
or i'm scared or i don't know what to do
um without any fear of humiliation or
retribution but rather to say these
things with the absolute confidence that
someone on our team will rush to support
us
unfortunately we also all know what it
feels like not to work on a trusting
team
where admitting any of those things
could hurt your chances of promotion
could hurt your chances of it you could
be humiliated
um and so when we when we work on teams
where leadership is creating an
environment where there's where trust is
a at a premium
we force our people to come to work and
lie hide and fake
where they're pretending that they've
made no mistakes
they're lying hiding and faking and
eventually things will crack and things
will eventually break and and when you
talk about reinvention and you talk
about innovation and you talk about
challenging the status quo or whatever
it is
necessarily there's risk and necessarily
there are mistakes and necessarily
there's stupid ideas
and you have to create an environment
which that's good
the alternative is everybody playing it
safe which is not the way that leads to
to vast or significant improvement